تفاقم الثلوج معاناه النازحين شمال سوريا
الاف العائلات المهجره تائن تحت وطاه ظروف
مناخيه شديده القسوه الخيام التي اثقلتها
الثلوج وانهار بعضها لم تمنع عنهم تسرب
مياه الامطار
خمس قيام بالليل لهلا
اطفال تحت الامطار وتحت الثلوج وين وين
الناتحين في ريف حلب الشمالي يتردد صداها
في مخيمات ادلب غياب لشبكات الصرف الصحي
وانتشار لبرك المياه الاسنه يعرقل الوحل
حركه الاطفال والشيوخ ويحول دون دخول مياه
الشرب للمخيم تسرب مياه الامطار الى
الخيام مع انخفاض درجات الحراره جعل
غالبيه الاطفال في المخيم عرضه للمرض بحسب
الاهالي
والله وشايفين الوضع شلون وشايفين الطين
شلون وشايفين كل شيء والله العظيم ما ابو
شيء من البرد عاد يموتون
استجابه سوريا من ازدياد الاوضاع
الانسانيه للنازحين مع توقعات باستمرار
تساقط الثلوج في الايام القادمه ودعا جميع
المنظمات الانسانيه الى توفير الدعم
اللازم للمخيمات بشكل عاجل وخصوصا مواد
التدفئه حيث يعتمد اغلب النازحين في تامين
الدفء لاطفالهم على اغصان الزيتون وما
يجمعونه من الاقمشه والبلاستيك من مكبات
النفايات
يشكو لها لضعف استجابه المنظمات الانسانيه
ووكالات الغوص ويطالبون المجتمع الدوليه
بتامين عوده كريمه لمدنهم وبلداتهم على
امل ان تنتهي معاناتهم التي تتكرر فصولها
مع كل الشتاء
ادهم ابو الحسامه الجزيره